a 33 second sony logo that tells you
that it's sony at the beginning and
mentions that Columbia Pictures is a
Sony company at the end is the sonia's
thing ever
also 50 seconds of logos is capitalism
at its finest / worst lavash say you can
find whatever they wish in Turkey how
about a man who kidnapped his own
daughter man Robert couldn't have
written a better scenario to set up the
ass-kicking he's about to provide also
apparently everyone involved creatively
with the equalizer finished the film
bathed in the surprising box office hall
and collectively agreed clearly he goes
to Turkey in disguise after this right
until they dangerous for you we're just
a prominent film or two using the away
from declaring it would be dangerous dot
dot dot for you an official cliche even
so it's old and tired and sinful and
somehow it was done better in the
fucking Dark Knight Rises opening scene
the zoom on denzel's eye is supposed to
tell us something about how he thinks
before he does some serious ass beating
just like the last one did but it gives
us the half-ass version here like even
the movie itself is disinterested in how
easy this fights gonna be also I don't
know if it's a stylistic choice or a
reflection of the fact that Denzel
badass that he is is 63 years old but
the very first action sequence of this
discount taken franchises sequel has
approximately 777 cuts in 12 seconds a
dramatic title screen blam moment after
that opening scene not earned that
opening scene was baffling at best
mediocre second cousin at worst that was
like the soggy toast of opening action
scenes in case you confused it with
Boston South Dakota also Boston State
Department doesn't know a thing about it
grace no one does
just that 45 minutes ago someone
delivered your daughter to the desk
downstairs was it Batman I'll bet it was
Batman always tends out wasn't it it's
20 second long time lapse cityscape
shots like this that bloat this movie to
just over two hours long I'm just saying
this stealth training cameo by the
Winklevoss twins all but confirms my fan
theory that the social network is part
of the ECU this is just like Logan only
without the gratuitous boobs or the
really excellent film all around this
scene that accepted
the last four minutes of this movie have
played like an episode of lyft
confessions headed correct
I'm here to pick you up when you get
back well just fly to Iraq put on to the
skies and kill all the enemies there
like you did in Turkey at least go in as
this guy's partner and watch his back 12
minutes in and this movies still around
taking its time like it's definitely got
my attention no matter what and it does
not let me see some story in case you
confused it with brussels australia who
sends their kids to school and a lift
but this lyft driver turns out to be a
human trafficker instead of a lethal
vigilante of justice then all these kids
parents are negligent assholes right
minecraft man was list under books
everyone should read this scene is
important because we need to know that
the mom of the girl Roberts saved at the
beginning of the movie runs his favorite
bookstore so far this movie is like
you've got mail or 84 Charing Cross Road
with more assassins I'm surprised with
as much lift product placement as this
movie has it wasn't called the equal
lift or two somehow all this guy's lift
customers are extra dramatic and also
all seem prone to verbalizing their
thoughts credit card was invalid look I
know these evil rich pricks are probably
stupid in addition to being list but I'm
gonna assume that most assholes know
they couldn't have even gotten the ride
if the credit card was invalid but you
hang with us cuz your daddy's a client
you've got the first thing I'm so glad
up ahead of Kappa beta phase could tell
us exactly what relationship he has with
the dude who ordered the lift tonight
I'm gonna need your camera's cell phones
anything you might have used to record
what you did to her in a city of
millions he drives around in a paid taxi
waiting for a person crying that he can
avenge he's Batman with a taxi but only
focusing on sex crimes this guy made
more sense when he was sticking up for
the hooker he knew from multiple
encounters of the diner now that he's
just out cruising for reasons to beat
ass and cut people he seems like Patrick
Bateman with a slight moral advantage
but I don't want root for a person like
that for reasons that I think are a
hundred percent to create a cool movie
shot moment and nothing else this guy
starts his stopwatch prior to this hotel
penthouse beatdown after Roberts beat up
two guys in devastating fashion this
dumb Hess tries to fight him for some
reason like maybe go ahead and punch
yourself at this point right so 29
seconds great you beat the ass-kicking
speed records set by Quicksilver awesome
didn't robert tell the one guy he needed
their cell phones and cameras and he
been left without any uh also he told
the other dude called 9-1-1 but
apparently robert's lift rating was more
important than that after the scene I
can't tell if the cops were called or if
the recording devices were confiscated
hello this is the Melissa Leo character
from the first movie so she had the kind
of relationship with Robert where she
didn't just break into his apartment and
everything's cool had that thing in
Turkey turn out ah happy ending no pun
intended
what because mom owns a bookstore I got
a mole over whether that rates as a punk
I was folding laundry the other day and
I realized that I didn't have any
clothes left that Vivian had never seen
King skipped mr. Makar maybe you could
find out who did this the Fatima's
garden I actually find it impossible to
believe mr. McCall would live in an
apartment complex that didn't have
security cameras at least without
installing his own which would should
make this a quick mystery to solve
but alas gang should make the building
do that now Roberts having a discussion
with a guy about who should clean the
graffiti off the walls we're in the 29th
minute of this movie does it ever start
she's still out here doing this miles
would be amazing at cinema since also
for the second day that we've seen at
least he's out here fixing the graffiti
and yeah he's a lyft driver so he works
what he wants and he can take as many
days off as he likes but he's not
super-rich he lives here with regular
phone he works for lyft when he kills
it's not a high dollar contract it's
vigilante justice and he doesn't get
paid and Duke buys airline tickets to
Turkey every few months according to
this movie and then st. cheat point is
he's not rich enough to be this
voluntary a southern president Whitmore
also Bill Pullman makes his grand
entrance into the equalizer too only to
tell us he's gonna Pullman out it's an
imperfect but reasonable method of
Pullman control looks like it's coming
off stone look just because dude is
using yo to speak doesn't mean this
isn't a storm is coming cliche once
again for the new viewers we do not need
text for place names when you're
establishing shot also includes
monuments recognized the world over as
being part of a particular city so much
Hey Poland's gone again he is the best
at exiting scenes I'm half expecting
Angela Bassett to show up in this thing
just to do an exit battle the director
said I want to come up with the best
representation of Washington apples and
this is what he came up with in case you
confused it with brussels australia a
second time Melissa Leo is investigating
a crime one that happened 20 minutes ago
in movie time and that was ignored in
favor of lift infinity war my dinner
with Susan
and 35 minutes of paint drying the movie
not just this graffiti incident but this
old guy trying to get a rare painting of
a sister back and I'm just saying none
of you remember the scene in the movie
and if you say you do you're lying
oh he's in his house let me just warn
folks out there driver or rider it
doesn't lyft or uber rides together it
does not mean you should invite the
other into your house holy this is how
you get killed my uncle commissioned the
blood threat does this have something to
do with the guy getting killed in
Brussels or the graffiti or the
bookstore owner's daughter or the preppy
rapist guys in case you confused it you
know three times telling us where
Brussels is unlocks a special tents in
addition rule joy
holy Christ has the entire first 40
minutes been setting up her incident
that propels the equalizer into action
Wow I didn't say anything
this is twice now conversations have
come to a halt with the person who was
talking asking the other person what and
getting me I didn't say anything
response
holy Christ the entire first 43 minutes
have just been setting up the inciting
incident I'm flabbergasted y'all flapper
King gasps did this move he thinks it's
breaking rules in a good way but really
it's just doing random for the sake of
doing random I will bet five million
sins that Dave was behind Susan's murder
this is basically Pedro Pascal's roll
these days the seemingly good guy who
has secret bad guy motives no sin for
now but five million if it's true I hear
if you shoot your protagonist through a
rain-soaked window it creates empathy
with in the audience for him/her much
like tears would 101 you've now told us
this four times in the span of 50
minutes here's another 30 cents
Ruby spends a few seconds trying to make
you feel what a drug addict feels which
doesn't fit the tone of the film thus
far and it's also kind of ripping off
requiem for a dream things to remember
as this storm continues its march
northward we saw what frizzes did
why is the radio talking about hurricane
Frances a hurricane that made landfall
in 2004 and a name that was retired
shortly after all the damage it did back
then in the script for this section of
the movie it just says and then 10
minutes of Denzel doing research on a
laptop god this is the second time in
this movie you have unnecessarily
labeled Washington DC I never had a
chance to say how sorry I was about
doing this Widow is infecting this plot
someone give this movie some penicillin
so now he's a badass criminologist too
someone take the scripts for the
equalizer sequel and The Bone Collector
sequel and mash them together so movie
barely feels anything like the first
equalizer movie barely know it was about
to figure out who was in that room
that's why she was killed - yeah - what
connected my question is why did Robert
go through all this trouble to reach out
to Dave even if he was once his trusted
partner you mean the idea that Dave
might be behind this never occurred to
him there was only really one person who
would know whether she was close to
solving this murder and that's this guy
knife wound requires its own post-it
note I helped the Susan Plummer murder
cases hit a snag time to equalize some
drug dealers one I thought you want to
join now what you said I love how this
kid's life dilemmas somehow between art
and murder man a spell G you win son no
one will be seated during the
after-school special portion of the
movie also I'm sure that this
after-school special was called Man 8
spell GU and Sun so roll credits you
have no idea what that is man King Kong
ain't got on this Denzel performance I
bet Ashton Sanders was convinced he was
a drug dealer in real life and made sure
he stopped being a drug dealer despite
never being lost I'm not your mom and
that's not your pot and this is not your
house how's that we trying to get that
kid out of the gang life or teach him
manners
get your my fair lady out of my r-rated
beatdown movie guess you don't fly that
often been driving in the opposite
direction of Logan for the last three
minutes how does a would-be assassin
decide which lyft driver he's gonna get
is that even possible
also this would-be assassin picks a king
knife for his weapon of choice because
of course he did well he keeps driving
and hand to handing this knife attack or
I'm left wondering why he doesn't have a
gun or a knife in the car you can use
himself right now
oh now comes the gun robert puts the
phone in this guy's hand and without any
other action the phone suddenly starts
showing him javascript or whatever
though this is a spurning car straight
out a man on fire now I'm starting to
think Denzel and Fuqua intentionally
peppered this forgettable action sequel
with references and similarities to
other films Denzel has made throughout
his career
I bet before this movie's over his
character will even be given a reason to
go to Mecca and say this ain't no bank
robbery it simply can't be a coincidence
that in the burning car pan up there's a
giant windmill and then we cut directly
to a shot of a house covered in solar
panels this movie was definitely not
funded by the fossil fuel industry
they're all boys it movie goes a long
way to try and make it seem like Dave's
wife might be dead but since dave ranks
extremely low on the good guy
believability scale this is pretty much
for nothing it's almost like the people
who made this movie didn't know who to
cast for this role and somehow watched
both the Great Wall and Kingsman to the
night before they made their decision as
Robin would call the wheat the apartment
tenants call him mr. McComb but this guy
was his old teammate and saw him die and
went to his funeral and was shocked to
see dude still alive earlier in the film
so is the movie saying Denzel faked his
own death but then carried on living
under his given name because that's the
kind of thing I like to call a sinful
this is of course no surprise so I'm
adding my five million sins now it was
the easiest investment I ever made also
why is Robert pushing this right now
when he just met Dave's innocent family
right here at his home I can't this wait
why didn't he tell Dave to meet him
somewhere so it didn't take place in
front of his wife and kids
Susan dangerous world man she obviously
knew there was a risk that she'd be
murdered in cold blood for money by her
partner and it's over five million so
these guys gonna be paying for a long
time maybe the last airbender can give
you some tips on how to deal guess what
there is no saying hey look I know
people just want to shut the cinemasins
operation down because we suck so
terribly hard but you're gonna have to
do better than make the guy who's the
surprise bad guy in every film he's in
your champion that's Tyrion how that
went they trained us to kill people and
risk our lives doing it and then one day
you get a call saying they're done with
you
thank you for your service is a plaque
this guy is super angry about this but
he's describing an honorable discharge
like they took part of his soul by
asking him to stop killing and I can't
relate Dave's family ex machina he
literally walked in the house this
morning as a stranger but this little
girl loves strangers so much that she
runs out into the street to beg hug him
back to the SUV with them so Denzel and
Oberon's former crew is made up of from
left to right Kong's go island chris
pines bon jovi loving cousin mitch and a
michael that is half Fassbender half
stole bark who's coming after me man who
killed Susan why cuz you're a little sad
you see though what does he know that
would lead to any of the bad guys in
this movie and why haven't they killed
him already if that's the case also you
let him take you from your home in
daylight drive for hours and check into
a hotel then looked out the window
during a downpour before asking this new
movie I like how the gang just left this
kid alone after he was abducted from
their mitts by gunpoint they never went
to visit or recruit him again and thank
goodness because now the assassin
looking for Denzel has a hostage for
later also why did these highly trained
assassins think Denzel would go back to
his own hole these are some incredibly
stupid highly trained assassins Myles
good thing Myles decided to call right
now since two killers are about to break
into Roberts place to murder it and why
is Myles calling right now you got any
food around him he's calling about food
like he can't just look in the kitchen
and find the food does he think Robert
hides turkey legs and the couch cushions
here are the levels of King Bulls
Robert had to weed through to hear
burking first off he's in a car that
makes noise second off it's raining and
that should drown out most everything
from the rain itself to all the pounding
on the car sir this is a cell phone
connection never the best of picking up
a wide range of sound fourth there's
another layer of rain that barking has
to go through on miles is in Robert
can't hear that and your total phony if
you say otherwise if you're gonna go
through the subterfuge of being a pizza
delivery guy well I pulled a gun out
right now you're trying to fool one of
your fellow highly trained military guys
right I know a home invasion expert but
it seems like this method of killing a
guy like Robert wouldn't work you're not
even trying to protect yourself
you walk through his door like you
expect him to be sitting there eating
cereal in his kitchen with no idea what
all those sounds were before you came in
there no good reason at all Pedro
Pascal's character will know there's a
compartment behind this bookcase shut up
miles you know there are dudes outside
looking for you Denzel repeatedly
shushed you why do you keep talking
miles I hate you amazing that when the
phone rings and Robert tells Dave that
attend that Dave doesn't think he's
calling from the secret room
he immediately incorrectly assumes
there's a camera in here sure would have
been nice to text miles to stay in the
secret room huh but why do that when the
bad guys need a bargaining chip and
miles stupidly walks out to check if
they're gone so glad that the hurricane
Francis subplot could make an appearance
by the end of this film I was just
thinking this movie needs a non Rubin
Carter hurricane to feel complete towns
been evacuated you know Dave pulled the
trigger he's definitely the murderer
here but Robert is a hundred percent
responsible for this guy's death there
was no need to have a showdown in an
evacuated area thank you Wow all clear
coming out that house must be hella
small it cleared in two seconds also I
don't know one of these guys need to
kill Robert with a hurricane on the way
maybe they're worried that Robert will
talk or provide evidence for their
wrongdoing but seriously he could have
done that a long time ago so the idea
that they'd have to kill him right now
is pretty laughable fidgets telling me
that in the middle of a fing hurricane
this asshole decided to go full sniper
mode seriously
he has never fired a sniper rifle and
wins this high Garant goddamn t it but
whatever
instead of ear cam like Peele view of
his sideburns who asked for that at
least there's a bunch of odd hanging
plastic rectangles in here to keep
things climax e a Rube Goldberg a what's
that over there and a harpoon only in
the film's climax is it trying to be
like its predecessor but even then it's
half-assing things Robert bothered and
had time to do this for some stupid
reason this guy who's supposed to have
roughly the same training as Robert is
so enamored with the photo of Susan that
he forgets every bit of it and becomes
an easy target the equalizer is
addictive sugar for salt maybe it's
flour but I doubt it regardless this is
wasteful I don't know who the kid is Mac
or if he means anything to you I took
the chance that he matters I know you
wanted to kill Robert without playing
your hostage card but good god man you
could have played this hours ago and
avoided the hurricane showdown the wind
makes it interesting interesting
I would guess it would make all your
sniping impossible given the sheer speed
of these winds but you went with
interesting which is interesting
basically Dave had all the time in the
world to kill miles and make Robert sad
but the hurricane finally matters at the
most crucial point which I guess is what
Robert was counting on that guy can
predict everything I remember when fight
scenes used to mean something when they
used to have doubt here we have our
villain and our hero fighting atop a
tower in a hurricane and there's zero
doubt who will win jeez how many eye
gouging is can one actor take in a
career no joke the original title of
this movie was watching the rain but it
was deemed too boring
it's nice miles redid the painting of
this woman's homeland on the wall but
did miles do this in secrecy behind a
green curtain of some sort or has this
woman been gone for the entire time
miles painted this thing resident by
Nature this guy has great news for this
elderly resident who's been obsessed
with finding his sister and his sister's
portrait but nearly gives the due to
heart attack by not coming straight out
with it
[Music]
I made up my mind to turn my body into a
weapon how come you never liked me like
you who the hell said I got to like you
what law is there say I got to like you
want to stand up in front of my face and
as a damn fool last question like that
talking about liking somebody come here
boy when I talk to you I'm putting cases
on all you bitches I wish you had more
time
and then one day you get a call saying
they're done with you
thank you for your service I got a medal
to Jack a medal and a pink slip and I'm
sorry about your hand
no it was you Fredo
you broke my heart I look at you I don't
see an intelligent confident man I see a
cocky scared this kid back there are no
good and bad people anymore there are
evil guys and innocent guys it's just a
bunch of guys there's a Rick that held a
factory hostage after murdering his boss
with several co-workers the factory made
cookies he made us all take a look at
what we were doing and in the bargain he
got a taste of real freedom